broue hinchada nous a boy and the women
si amar est la denrée dông da luz comme
of lautoa vm n'avait gardoise haut doubs
firme amène chine au silencio lente où
on trouve adore chez io gistré
et jusqu'où tago la n5 une fiche blue
jays qui sert louise bonsoir je suis
comptable de formation à 10 ans mes
premiers pas sur scène
le bourgeois gentilhomme j'étais bien
c'était beau papa maman plus tard je
serai comédienne j'aime la scène
j'en ai pas fait tout de suite à 15 ans
tous les jours avant de partir à l'école
ma brosse à cheveux dans les mains je
chantais je chantais tous les tubes pop
qui passait à la radio devant mon miroir
je chantais je me croyais papa maman
plus tard je serai chanteuse le bac
et puis l'orientation pas facile j'ai
choisi la comptabilité
bah oui c'est bien il faudrait que je
rentre quand même dans une case rentrer
dans un moule c'est un peu plus
rassurant donc je fais mes études de
comptabilité j'étais pas très bonne est
en 2e année fin de deuxième année
le prof de compta monsieur koch me dit
mademoiselle quand j'avais votre âge
j'avais une passion
le cyclisme est bien j'ai choisi je peux
le dire ce soir
merci monsieur coche il m'a aidé il m'a
aidé à trouver ce que j'avais envie de
faire du cyclisme
j'avais envie de chanter je pense que
s'il n'avait pas dit cette phrase ça
n'aurait pas fait égaux alors ensuite
j'ai continué forcément mes études de
comptabilité
bah oui il faut être logique je suis
parti en espagne une année erasmus mais
une année où j'ai aussi chanté dans la
rue avec des musiciens ou g
pris des cours de tango c'était le début
de de la liberté et puis un hasard je
suis rentrée à lille
je ne me voyais pas comptable dans une
entreprise non pas encore en tout cas
et je me suis dit il faudrait que je
puisse partir et et que j'essaie de
donner cette chance de faire de la
musique essayé et j'ai eu la chance de
partir un an aux états unis alors aux
états unis c'était un peu comme dans le
film fame à orly forez
voilà c'était ça y est j'étudie enfin ce
qui me fait vibrer c'était beau c'était
alors j'avais j'ai fait tout ce que j'ai
pu j'en ai mangé r j'en ai de la musique
du jazz yeux de la musique classique de
l'harmonisation du solfège tout ce que
je pouvais faire en musique
ça y est c'était pour moi et puis quand
je suis rentré ce qui est drôle c'est
que je suis parti juste une année avant
de partir j'étais la copine sympa qui
est à l'aise en public
et puis à la fin d'un dîner alice tu
veux pas nous chanter une chanson pas de
problème à la fin d'un mariage alice tu
veux pas chanter une chanson pas de
problème je suis parti aux états unis
et quand je suis rentré j'ai des
chanteuses chanteuse professionnelle et
en fait c'est quoi être chanteuse s'est
partagé quand je chante sur scène je
partage avec le public
il est là le public je partage avec le
public
je suis sur scène je partage avec des
musiciens et c'est d'ailleurs fabuleux
quand je fais de la musique je partage
avec les jeunes avec qui je fais je
dirige une chorale par exemple ou quand
je donne un cours de chant je partage
vraiment la musique c'est le partage
et puis il ya deux ans olivier un
ingénieur du son appel en disant alice
l'entreprise disney vient de me
contacter il ya une fête pour leurs
salariés
il nous demande d'installer un studio
d'enregistrement et les collaborateurs
vont venir chanter pendant la soirée
et alors là j'y crois pas du tout je lui
dis quelle drôle d'idée mais personne
n'a envie de chanter pour alice des
payer si disney tu viendras oh bah ouais
je viens on verra bien et alors là
incroyable les gens faisaient la queue
pour venir chanter et alors ils venaient
chanter une fois une deuxième fois avec
d'autres collègues
ça y est ils étaient les gens viennent
chanter ah bon les gens aiment chanter
d'accord vous aimez chanter on va voir
et donc voilà vraiment grande surprise
donc on a fait une première fois pour
disney on l'a fait plusieurs fois et là
je me suis dit mais cette envie de
partager et compris que c'est quelque
chose qui m'anime
vraiment je me suis dit je vais créer ma
petite entreprise et avec les qui a pour
but donc de partager cette passion de la
musique en faisant de la cohésion des
équipes par la musique
alors c'est vrai quand j'arrive dans une
entreprise et que je dis bonjour
aujourd'hui nous allons chanter les gens
sont ravis
et pourquoi parce qu'en fait le chant
c'est hyper intime c'est vrai je suis
sûr que vous êtes dans votre voiture
pas de problème pour chanter à tue-tête
a pas de problème mais devant les autres
c'est beaucoup plus difficile parce que
c'est impliquant donc c'est vrai que pas
si simple et en même temps tout le monde
peut chanter tout le monde peut chanter
un enfant n'arrête pas de chanter un
enfant quand il vient au monde commence
par crier par chanter tout le monde peut
chanter
vous avez envie de chanter d'accord
alors c'est vrai que juste géante est
bon plein d'un plein de visages que j'ai
croisés dans les entreprises je me
souviens d'une personne en fauteuil
roulant et quand je les fais chanter
elle était impressionnante parce qu'
elle ne m'a pas lâché du regard est pire
que ça elle n'a pas cligner des yeux
pendant toute la chanson elle m'a
regardé comme ça et elle chantait il
chantait et à se donner
c'était magnifique et puis je me
souviens d'une autre personne quand je
lui ai dit qu'elle allait chanter elle
m'a bien fait comprendre qu'elle n'avait
pas envie de chanter
hélas ce qui est drôle c'est que une
demi heure après elle avait pris le
casque le micro il y avait plus de place
pour personne elle avait envie de
chanter
en fait elle est probablement un
complexe parce que forcément quand on
veut on dit on va chanter ah oui mais on
écoute toujours à la radio des super
grand chanteur ben oui même moi même moi
même quand j'ai commencé à chanter je
suis passionné de jazz la plus grande
chanteuse ella fitzgerald quand je
l'écouté chanter ma josé pas chanter un
sujet pareil
mais à partir du moment où on se dira
oui voilà il ya des grands qui peuvent
chanter mais tout à l'heure j'ai chanté
devant vous je ne suis toujours pas ella
fitzgerald toujours pas je l'admirais
toujours autant et pourtant mes jeux
donc je pense que l'on de ces chanter
les gens aiment chanter
et puis chanter ça fait du bien alors je
vous propose maintenant de vous mettre
debout vous mettre en condition
alors peut-être commencer par faire
c'est simple on s'est tiré l'as est tiré
il soit à lui même le père tient ou
deuxième froid et puis éventuellement
vous allez même bâiller en faisant du
bruit en user les nerfs
allez encore il nous fallait en ouvrant
vraiment la bouche
c'est si bien et maintenant je sais que
vous avez pas beaucoup de place on va
faire droite gauche droite gauche donc
j'avance je recule et on va essayer de
ne pas accélérer d'accord donc moi je
vais on va pas arrêter de le faire donc
droite
bush s'il public est superbe on pourra
même taper dans les mains sur le 2004
n'ont par exemple si je fais un super
beau
vous savez je savais qu'ils étaient bon
ok
attention ça va se compliquer on va
arrêter le bain pour l'instant les
partants de continuer les pieds toujours
en fait tout simplement comme ça on a la
même pulsation et donc on va chanter ce
que vous voyez bien mes mains ok donc si
je vous fais un bout ça à faire
attention quoi
le
attention piège
ok vous êtes super beau super bon vous
n'arrêtez pas les pieds je veux juste
vous dire quelque chose
c'est la première fois que je le fais
alors maintenant on va séparer public
ici vous allez avoir cette main là ici
cette voie là
ok on est prêt
e
pour rester sur le rhin
je
papon
la veille
la ville de vannes
les
diana bravo c'est magnifique